yeah i was tagged by ridima you should
watch
her book tag video which is excellent
i'm gonna go right ahead and just get
into these questions
fantasy reader book tag it's gonna be
it's gonna be fun
it's gonna be fun what is your fantasy
origin story
let's be real my fantasy origin story
begins
and ends with the chronicles of narnia i
read the magician's nephew
i think for second grade we were
supposed to read the lion the witch in
the wardrobe little did i know it was
published much later and is actually the
prequel i had no idea that it was all
christian illusions and all that i
didn't get any of that but
yeah that series was just magical i
especially love
the horse and his boy which is kind of
underrated i think
also a fantasy book that i love was the
phantom
[ __ ] toll booth what a great
funny
hilarious book i read that a few times
also
the a wrinkle in time series i was
really into science fiction
uh early on but i and i like read a lot
of old
like jules verne and h.g wells i was
really into that a wrinkle in time kind
of
it it's hard to classify it because it's
not exactly
it's sort of science fiction but it's
also fantasy
and also kind of children's but also not
really so and then i read you know
harry potter who didn't read harry
potter if you could be the hero of a
fantasy novel who would be the author
and what's one trope you'd insist on
being
in the story i would want stephen king
to write the book where i'm the hero
but that's not because i've been reading
a lot of stephen king lately
because stephen king's really good at
just writing ordinary lives
with a dash of like really interesting
crazy stuff in it i like to think i'm
just a regular guy
and one trope i'd insist on is the nerdy
character
who doesn't really like do anything
significant and is like cowardly
but then it gets really impulsive and
does like something crazy courageous
like uh
neville in the seventh harry potter book
because i'm i'm
generally across the board a coward in
life there'd have to be a
also a meet cute kind of uh romance plot
because i like those and that's kind of
how my
my wife and i met so that that'd be in
there what is a fantasy book
you've read this year that you want more
people to read
the dark tower i mean specifically the
drawing of the three because
for a fantasy book it's like action
thriller it's insane that's what i love
about the dark tower series i feel like
each book is uniquely
different an upcoming fantasy release
you're excited for i honestly i cannot
like
i can't think of a single one honestly i
don't know what's new i i'm not reading
a lot of newer
fantasy books and that's that's my issue
that's something i want to correct in
2021 i want to read more modern fantasy
what is one misconception about fantasy
uh that you'd like to lay to rest
the idea that fantasy is all game of
thrones
you know dragons kind of stuff like the
fantasy encompasses
so much it is so inclusive of
tropes and genres i think there's this
idea that fantasy writers and fantasy
books have to be limited to a certain
type of
world certain type of world building
certain type of magic system
fantasy is the breaking of expectations
the greatest stories that we love are
our fantasy you know
mythological tales storytelling is
fantastical
you know so if someone had never read a
fantasy before and asked you to
recommend the first three books that
comes to mind
as places to start what would those
recommendations be
read uh the lion the witch in the
wardrobe read the gunslinger
and the hobbit it's a weird mixture i
picked there i guess you should probably
read um i don't know read the way of
kings too go for it
i don't know anyways i hope i did some
kind of
justice to that book tag truly i'd like
to thank rituma for
tagging me in this this was a lot of fun
i would like to tag
some people as well shipwrecked library
i mean come on it's shipwrecked library
pablo suarez who is making really good
content yasmine jasmine b reading one of
my favorite channels
andy smith amazing zach at middle
fantasy
recently did a really great workout
training
video for uh bridge runs like in
stormlight archive so
those are the people i'm tagging this is
my fantasy story thank you for watching
bye
you